une page se tourne pour le club de
fitness et de musculation de villepreux
créée en 1968 l'association est
désormais implanté depuis le lundi 7
mars à fontenay le fleury au gymnase du
levant la raison le merville président
stéphane mirambeau n'a pas renouveler le
bail de la salle les locaux que nous
mettions à disposition du club de
musculation n'était absolument plus en
phase avec l'ambition que portait ce
club
cette salle était beaucoup trop petit
nous avons d'ailleurs participé au fait
qu'ils puissent aller à fond telle furie
vu que nous avions soutenu directement
leur souhait c'est sa décision je sais
pas voilà pour faire de la politique non
plus mais là pour gérer une association
qui a précédé son choix on respecte
rebaptisé musculation fitness
fontenay-le-fleury le club dispose d'une
salle de 225 mètres carrés à l'arrière
du gymnase contre 160 m² dans les
anciens locaux du centre sportif a nommé
mme houde et géra qu'elle est un petit
peu mieux parce que c'est un peu plus
neuf et un peu plus neuf
un peu plus chaud pour l'hiver le club
qui comptait 2 147 adhérents début
septembre espère attirer de nouveaux
sportifs avec cette nouvelle salle les
gens de fontenay vont je pense peut-être
ce groupe est plus sûr plaisir ou mais
on va voir une autre population quoi
c'est à dire qu'on va voir les gens de
saint cyr de bois d'arcy fontenay même
bailly qui sont proches l'inauguration
officielle est programmée ce samedi 12
mars dans l'après midi en présence des
élus de fontenay le fleury